other good news just a few moments ago
we learned
that britain's prince philip was
transferred to a different hospital in
london where he will continue to receive
treatment for an infection mcqueen's
husband
due to turn 100 in june is expected to
stay in the hospital until at least at
the end of the week
philip is said to be comfortable and
responding to treatment
wishing him well meanwhile we have a
sneak peek at oprah winfrey's highly
anticipated
exclusive interview with prince harry
and megan duchess of sussex
in this clip harry talks about his late
mother princess diana and the public
pressure on her
take a look i can't begin to imagine
what it must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
because it has been unbelievably tough
for the two of us but at least we have
each other
my biggest concern i keep saying this
every time we do the story no
subject was off limits the preview shows
oprah telling the couple
you've said some pretty shocking things
here
harry and megan stepped away from
full-time royal life one year ago and
last month
buckingham palace confirmed the couple
won't return to royal duties
oprah with megan and harry a cbs
primetime special has been extended
to two hours yeah it airs on sunday
night right here on
cbs probably a lot more and
as you said last week oprah said about
this interview that
she believes it's the best she's ever
done and she said it was more than it
wasn't just her though is because
the conversation apparently was so
candid
with all three of them they all look
comfortable seeing you talking the
preview clips are incredible yeah i
think so too one point harry talks about
being worried about history repeating
itself
yes they taped at a friend's home people
said it was at oprah's house or harry
may it was at a friend's house all right
thank you